If you ever go to a music festival,
especially a music festival in the UK,
you might come across the problem that
there's always lots of toilets for you
to choose from
and the problem with these toilets is
they're not always that well
looked after.
And I have been to quite a few music festivals,
and numerous times have I come
across this problem.
Nubmerphile
Featuring Dr. Ria Symonds
Video by Brady Haran
Animation by Pete McParlan
So, the mathematical part of this problem is:
Let's say that you're in the queue
and you get to the first toilet
and you open the door
and it's really not that nice.
You really don't want to use that toilet.
So it's OK. You can try the next toilet.
You open the door, but it might be
marginally better but still not that good.
The problem is you've got
hundreds of these toilets,
and how do you know which toilet
to stop on
and decide "Yeh, I'm going to
use that toilet,"
so you don't have to try them all.
There must be a certain number,
an optimum number we can look at.
So, there are two things that
we do need to stick to on this problem.
The first is that ideally
I'm looking for the best toilet,
the most hygienic,
the cleanest toilet.
One with plenty of toilet paper in there,
hand sanitizer... has been looked after.
Number two is that you can't go back
to a previous toilet.
There are people queuing behind you.
If you reject a toilet
you can't go back to it.
So I start with a small example
where the number toilets
is actually quite small
to begin with.
It's a small music festival,
just so that we can see what's happening.
So, there are my three toilets.
Now, I'm going to number them
1, 2 and 3,
and the numbers relate to
how hygienic they are.
So, number 1 is the best toilet,
the most hygienic.
Number 2 not quite as hygienic.
Number 3 the worst.
You certainly wouldn't want to choose this one.
OK, so the toilets at the moment
are lined up in this order.
but it's not necessarily going to be
always this order.
I could have came to the toilets
and actually number 1 might have been
in the first position
but number 3 could have been second
and number 2 could have been third.
And if you think about
the number of permutations
of the order of these toilets,
there are actually 4 more.
So there are 6 permutations,
which is 3 factorial.
So the likelihood that the first toilet
you are going to is the cleanest
is quite slim, especially if the number
of toilets gets larger.
So let's say that we're always
going to reject the first toilet,
and then will choose the next best
out of our options.
So if we take consideration
of the first example,
we're going to reject toilet 1,
even though it is the best,
I don't know it's the best
because I can't compare it yet.
I then take the best possible
option after that.
2 - when I compare it to 1 is worse,
so I can't take 2.
3 - although it is also worse
than 1 and 2,
I have no more toilets left to choose,
so, unfortunately, I have to go with
the worst toilet in this case.
Brady Haran: It's a bad ending.
Dr. Symonds: Bad ending.
If I take the second case,
again, I reject the first toilet,
3 is worse than 1 so I reject 3
and this time I have to select 2.
We move on to the third example.
I reject 2.
Now, 1 is better than 2,
so, because it is better, I choose
that one straight away and I stop.
I first reject 2 on the fourth example,
3 is worse than 2,
so I move on to the next toilet
and because it's the last toilet
I select that toilet.
And from here I reject 3,
1 is better than 3
so I select 1 and I stop.
Here is reject 3,
2 is better than 3
so this time I select 2
and I stop.
So if I take a look
at how many times
I actually chose the best toilet,
the most hygienic.
There are 1, 2, 3.
So there are 3 out of 6 chance,
or a half,
which is 50 percent chance
that one would have chosen
the correct most hygienic toilet.
OK, So this is fine for
when you have 3 toilets,
but what happens when
you have 4?
With 4 toilets
we now have 24 different permutations.
We have to consider every single one.
Now, if you work through it in the same way
we'll find that we're actually
only successful on
11 out of 24 of those opportunities,
which is a percentage of about
46 percent.
Brady Haran: This is successful for
finding the best possible toilet.
Dr. Symonds: The best possible toilet,
so toilet number 1.
So the percentage has already decreased
by only including one extra toilet.
As n gets larger, i.e.
the number of toilets gets larger,
this percentage gets smaller
and smaller and smaller.
So the idea of rejecting the first toilet
and taking the next best after that
is quite limited.
We can see that as n gets large
it doesn't give us an optimal solution.
So, of course at music festivals there are
hundreds of toilets,
so we'd like a solution that gives us
a better approximation for this percentage,
to give us a better likelihood of
finding the best toilet.
So we're going to do it
with a little bit of math.
Brady Haran: I'm going to stop the video here,
because as you probably guessed
things are about to get pretty mathematical.
So I'm going to give you a choice.
If you want to see all the mathematics
that leads to the answer here
go to the Numberphile 2 channel
and I have put all the rest of this video there.
It's a bit over 15 minutes long.
If you haven't got time for that,
you want to just get straight to the answer,
maybe you're late to
a music festival yourself,
stay here and we'll cut
straight to the chase.
But I do recommend the mathematics,
it's really interesting.
I think most people will follow it,
and there's more really good animations from Pete.
So... Make a choice...
I'll give you a second.
OK, So here is the deal.
Once Dr. Symonds has done all the mathematics,
it comes down to this.
The base thing to do is to look inside
37 percent of the toilets.
And after you hit that 37 percent
tipping point,
you choose the first toilet after that
that's better than everything that came before.
That gives you the best chance
of ending up in the best toilet.
That doesn't mean you can skip that
first 37 percent.
You've actually got to look inside
them unfortunately,
so that you can make the comparison
after you've gone past the tipping point,
after you've gone past that
37 percent.
To make it really simple
imagine Glastonbury, imagine a 100 toilets.
You got to look inside 37,
and after the 37th
pick the first one after that,
that's better than what came before.
Dr. Symonds: So we've used the example
of choosing the best toilet,
but this a famous mathematical problem
that you may have seen before
in a different context.
You may have heard of it before
called "The Secretary Problem",
which is the same process.
This time you want to find
the best secretary for the job,
but you were going to interview
an n number of people,
say maybe a 100 people.
You can only accept or reject each secretary
once they've been interviewed.
So when do you stop interviewing
those secretaries
and start accepting one of them
hoping that you have the best for the job?
Or another famous use of this
is in the dating world.
If you want to find the best partner,
your soul mate out there,
then how many people should you date
before you should start accepting
and settling down with that
next person
and hoping that that is the person
you're supposed to be with
for the rest of your life.
Brady Haran: Thanks for watching.
Just a reminder,
you can still go and look at all
the mathematics behind this
over Numberphile 2.
You've got all the stuff worked out
by Dr. Symonds
and more excellent animations
from Pete McPartlan.
We don't actually expect people to do this
at music festivals, by the way.
It's just a bit of a fun twist on
an old problem
that everyone talks about all the time.
We didn't want to make it about
secretaries and dating,
so, why not toilets?